[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
on a series called High School memories
my name is Ado and I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about the benefits of
learning a second language learning a
second language is an incredible journey
that can open doors to new experiences
connections and opportunities to help us
uncover the many advantages of becoming
bilingual or multilingual we've invited
a special guest today ashre Boku a
linguist language educator and author of
the book multilingualism the key to
richer life ashref welcome to the show
thank you for having me Addis it's a
pleasure to be here it's our pleasure to
have you let's dive right into it can
you tell us about some of the cognitive
benefits of learning a second language
absolutely learning a second language is
like a workout for the brain it enhances
cognitive abilities such as problem
solving creativity and critical thinking
bilingual IND uals often exhibit better
memory attention and are more adapt at
multitasking additionally it can delay
the onset of cognitive disorders like
Alzheimer's disease that's remarkable
it's as if learning a second language is
a gem for the mind what about the impact
on personal and professional
development learning a second language
can be a GameChanger it it enhances your
Global Perspective culture Al
sensitivity and adapt
adaptability this is invaluable in
today's interconnected World
professionally uh bilingualism can boost
your career prospects by making you more
marketable and increasing your earning
potential so it's not just about words
it's about Building Bridges both
personally and
professionally but let's not forget the
cultural aspects how does learning a
second language affect cultural
understanding uh learning a second
language is like stepping into another
world it allows you to gain insight into
different cultures their
traditions and their way of
thinking this promotes empathy and
cross-cultural
communication it's a password to connect
with people on a deeper
level that's a beautiful way to put it
it's about fostering connections and
understanding understanding now for our
listeners who might be considering
learning a second language do you have
any tips for or advice for them
certainly uh first choose the language
that genuinely interests you enjoyment
is key to staying
motivated second immerse yourself in the
language through books music and movies
practice regularly and if possible uh
find a language Exchange partner most
importantly be patient with yourself
language learning is a
journey great advice enjoy the process
immerse yourself and be
patient before we wrap up could you
share a personal anecdote related to
your multilingual
journey of course I once struggled to
learn a language and almost gave up
however I persisted and that language
became my strongest it taught me that
preservance is key and the moments of
challenge are often the ones that lead
to the most
growth an inspiring story and a great
reminder that the Journey of to
bilingualism is full of ups and downs
thank you for sharing that ASF and thank
you so much for joining us on this
episode of high school memories it's
been an incredible journey and we're so
glad you came along for the ride until
next time take
care and thank you our wonderful
listeners for tuning in to this episode
of high school memories we hope you're
inspired to embark on your own language
learning Journey remember the benefits
go far beyond just words they touch
every aspect of Our
[Music]
Lives